[Music]
late one night in 1871 a group of riders
descended on a sleeping army camp in
minutes they stirred the camp into a
panic stole about 70 horses and
disappeared led by a young chief named
Quanah Parker the raid was the latest in
a long series of altercations along the
Texas frontier between the indigenous
people known as the namana or Comanches
and the United States forces sent to
steal Comanche lands for white settlers
though the conflict was decades old u.s.
colonel Ronald Mackenzie led the latest
iteration from summer to winter he
tracked Quanah but Quanah was also
tracking him in each time the colonel
drew near his targets they disappeared
without a trace into the vast plains the
Comanches had controlled this territory
for nearly 200 years hunting Buffalo and
moving whole villages around the plains
they suppressed Spanish and Mexican
attacks from the south attempts to
settle the land by the United States
from the east and numerous other
indigenous peoples bids for power the
Comanche Empire was not one unified
group under central control but rather a
number of bands each with its own
leaders what all of these bands had in
common was their prowess as riders every
man woman and child was adept on
horseback their combat skills on
horseback far surpassed those of both
other indigenous peoples and colonists
allowing them to control an enormous
area with relatively few people probably
about 40,000 at their peak and only
about four to five thousand by the time
Quanah Parker and Ronald Mackenzie faced
off born around 1848 Quanah was the
eldest child of PETA Nocona a leader of
the no canoe band and Cynthia Ann Parker
a kidnapped white settler who
assimilated with the Comanches and took
the name Nadu ah
when Guana was a preteen US forces
ambushed his village
shirring his mother and sister Quanah
and his younger brother sought refuge
with a different Comanche band the
Claddagh in the years that followed Quan
approved himself as a warrior and leader
in his early 20s he and a young woman
named Wikia eloped enraging her powerful
father and several other leaders they
stayed on the run for a year
attracting followers and establishing
Quanah as a pariah or chief and an
exceptionally young age under his
leadership the kohada band was able to
elude the US military and continue their
way of life but in the early 1870s the
East Coast market for buffalo hides
became lucrative and hunters slaughtered
millions of Buffalo in just a few years
meanwhile US forces led a surprise
attack
killing nearly all the kohada bands
1,400 horses and stealing the rest
though he had vowed to never surrender
Quanah knew that without bison or horses
the Comanches face certain starvation in
winter so in 1875
Quanah and the kohada band moved to the
Fort Sill reservation in Oklahoma as
hunter-gatherers they could not
transition easily to an agricultural way
of life on the reservation the US
government had promised rations and
supplies but what they provided was
wildly insufficient Quantam meanwhile
was suddenly in a weak political
position he had no wealth or power
compared to others who had been on the
reservation longer still he saw an
opportunity the reservation included
ample grasslands useless to the
Comanches but perfect for cattle
ranchers to graze their herds he began a
profitable arrangement leasing the land
to cattle ranchers quietly at first
eventually he negotiated leasing rights
with the US government which ensured a
steady source of income for the
Comanches on the reservation
as quanis status on the reservation and
recognition from government officials
grew he secured better rations advocated
for the construction of schools and
houses and became one of three tribal
judges on the reservation court tired of
speaking with multiple leaders the US
government wanted to appoint one chief
of all Comanches a role that hadn't
existed outside the reservation still
many Comanches supported Quanah for this
role just as several older leaders had
supported him to lead them against the
u.s. armed forces even quanah's former
adversary
Ronald Mackenzie advocated for his
appointment Quanah acted in Hollywood
movies and befriended American
politicians riding in Theodore
Roosevelt's inauguration parade still he
never cut his long braids and advocated
for the Native American church and the
use of peyote he began to go by Quanah
Parker adopting his mother's surname and
tried to track down his mother and
sister eventually learning they had both
died shortly after their capture
Quanah adapted again and again to
different worlds different roles and
circumstances that would seem
insurmountable to most though he wasn't
without critics after quanah's passing
Comanches began using the term chairman
to designate the top elected official in
the tribe recognizing him as the last
chief of the Comanches and a model of
cultural survival and adaptation in that
spirit today's Comanche nation looks
towards the future with over 16,000
enrolled citizens and countless
descendants for another story of horse
riding warriors get to know the Amazons
who were these seemingly mythical
formidable fighters and how do we know
if they really existed find out what
this video
[Music]